Imagine a world where all of the things that keep your food fresh and plentiful no longer existed.
Imagine a world with no food choices or no specialty foods of any kind.
Imagine a world where nutrition is just a guessing game.
Imagine a world where the food you buy for your family is simply unsafe.
It's a scenario that could leave you feeling empty.
The good news?
Right now all around the world thousands of highly trained dedicated food science professionals...
...are preventing this frightening scenario from becoming a reality.
They're developing wholesome nutritious foods.
They're creating the packaging that keeps your food safe.
And they are making sure you have a variety of foods that are abundant, convenient, affordable...
...and delicious to keep you and your family healthy and happy.